hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the 2020 chasuble masters it's the
quarter finals and the first match is
Fabiana Caruana vs. Magnus Carlsen also
the other one is a young Republican
versus Ladislav Artemyev and like we
mentioned in the previous video the two
groups have now merged together and now
it's no longer preliminaries it's now
the Knockouts and like the like the
previous tournament in the Magnus right
chest where we will have each match will
be basically a set of three matches so
this is only the first match of four
games if it's if it's tied and of course
they go into into Armageddon until one
emerges victorious then the second and
in the third match it's the same like
we've like we've already covered so
without further ado let's check it out
this is the second game of their first
match and Fabi has the white pieces he
lost the first game to Magnus where
Magnus had the white piece so Fabi needs
a win to get back into the match with
efore by Fabi and we have E 5 by Magnus
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 sorry about
that
and Bishop to c4 so Bishop to c4 Magnus
goes for Bishop to c5 DP and the yoke of
piano game is on the board and here Fabi
does not go for the Evans gambit
unfortunately he goes for c3 continues
in the main line of the joke of piano so
Knight f6 we have D 3 and d 6 so just
the standard main line we have a 4 and
not enough preparing B 4 and B 4 and a 5
to trap the dark square Bishop so of
course Magnus make some room for the
bishop and the castles Magnus goes h6
doesn't allow any Bishop g5 and rook to
e1 we have castles bye-bye black and now
comes h3 also not allowing any and
bishop or Knight to g4 ideas with the
shorter e 6 and now Bishop to b5 just
attacking the knight which is one of the
pieces that fights for the control of
the center so here at 9th day 7 this is
the standard move here ended B for now
we've it captures C captures and now
there is a 1 game in the database where
the bishop just just moves to b4 puts
pressure on the rug but here Magnus
prepared Knight character son b5 and it
is as of move 13 that we have a complete
new game so now he leaves fob the option
of capturing here or capturing the
bishop here and if you go for the night
and Bishop to b4 come is again played it
goes after the rook and pretty much
pretty much runs into the same line
without the knight on a seven and the
bishop on b5 so here
Fabi goes for the characters on c5 he
gets rid of the bishop now there will be
no Bishop to b4 going after the rook and
now Magnus just goes back Knight the a7
we have capture some d6 Queen captures
and these six and here Fabi trades we
have characters and characters and
Magnus says I'm very happy here I won
the first game with the white pieces now
I have a fairly comfortable position
with black I do have three point islands
where as White has two but I will try to
keep this guy somehow well not not a
weakness at some point I'm gonna push it
to d5 and hopefully it will be okay so
Knight the c3 fabric continues
development in the Knights back to c6 I
will bash up to f4 now puts pressure on
the pawn here and well you could just
defend the pawn instead Magnus just
pushes that he doesn't want I want to
have a weak d6 pawn fob he pushes he 5
he says I'm still hoping this bone will
be weak so I don't want to trade it and
now and now Magnus decides to give up a
pawn for for some initiative so he goes
Knight to e4 he offers the pawn and the
Fabi accepts that we have Knight
captures on e4 d characters and the rook
captures on e4 so what did Magnus gain
for his pawn sacrifice well he want the
control of the D file for the moment
which is an important file to control
since now the rook is no longer on he
won and you cannot go rook rook a to d1
for example so look the c1 instead of
Fabi puts his rook on the other open
file which is the C file and now rook to
d3 a very active square for the rook
from there you can go after the B coupon
for example and it's just a well it's
just a very active square for the rook
you can double up on the default and so
on so if I be immediately challenges the
rook he doesn't want to allow Magnus to
just double up which he does but of
course now it's not for free Fabi will
eliminate one of the routes with
characters captures and now cross and
will go after the b2 upon and the
problem
you don't have any good ways of stopping
this for example if you try rook to c3
Magnus can just straight and just go
let's say there should be three and he
will win his pawn back so that's not the
issue
so here we have a really a nice example
of how activity is is a really a nice
well a nice trade-off for for an extra
pawn because you can always win it back
if you want so here at five he goes
Bishop to e3 he decides to give up at
the pawn in a different way we have
worked the b3 and now Knight to d4
sorry Knights the d4 by Fabi now saying
if you capture I'm gonna capture with
the bishop and guard my pawn here so he
goes for it with Knight captures Bishop
characters and rook the B for now so he
will not be winning the b-pawn but he
will win back the a pawn this is how far
we decided to give it back
Bishop to c3 and now just rook captures
an a4 so now a winning his pawn back and
the thing is even though the material on
the board is equal magnus has a
two-to-one advantage on the Queen side
and if he can get those pawns pushing
then sooner or later he will create a
passed pawn on the Queen side so here we
have g4 by favi probably with ideas of
King G - maybe g3 then f4 that's not a
for f4 maybe a five and so on so b5
Magnus continues playing on the Queen
side and Fabio's king g2 with his
counter play and the King side we have B
for pushing the bishop back Bishop to d4
and now comes B 3 will be a very strong
pawn since the bishop defensive and also
the bishop here is also under attack so
the show back to c3 and now look to 8
you preparing to go a 4 and a 3 that's
why it's it's sometimes very important
to realize that you have a two-to-one
advantage on one one side of the board
so rook the d1 by fabien now just a 4
now we have King to f3 also possible is
is f4 Bobby decides to go for a king to
f3 right away
so a 3 by Magnus and now if you capture
then you create a passed beep on so it
doesn't really matter if you character
or not if I we decided to block and now
a character son beat you
and it doesn't matter what Bobby
recaptures with since even if rook
Magnus of course will not trade drugs
you don't want to go into this opposite
colored bishop in game so far be first
characters with the bishop and now g5 by
Magnus saying that maybe maybe you
should have kept your King here and
gotten this point all the way to f4
because now at some point if you push f4
you will also ruin your nice pawn island
and you will you will then have to play
with to pawn islands so King III fob
makes a room for e4 t f4 pawn push we
have into h7 and now Fabi does go for f4
he could just wait and and see what
Magnus comes up with but he prefers some
activity so f4 we have G captures on
f-14 captures and King to g6 now by
Magnus with h4 now preparing something
like age 5 but now Magnus goes h5
himself and he says ok if you try
something like g5 then I can just go
it's a rook day for check you cannot
move the King since this will be a
weakness also there will be rook to g4
if you go to g3 so you'd have to block
with your rook but then I can just go
let's say Brooke e6 rook the c6 rook to
c2 and either force your bishop to move
and let's say push the pawn or just
create creator well some chances with a
much more active rook than it was on a 2
so far B doesn't like this instead he
captures on age 5 but now King
characters on h5 and the point is well
just attacked and there is no there is
no trick like if crossing characters
rook rook to h3 is made because you can
always block with the bishop so Fabi has
to defend the pawn rook to h2 but now
rook to a4 check by Magnus King to III
and now again if you just trade here yes
you can win a pawn but it's again an
endgame of opposite called bishops which
white can very easily draw so it's not
not very interesting
so Magnus instead finds a very sneaky
idea he goes King to g4 he wants to play
King here attack the route King here
attack the rook and after the rook moves
just gobble up the pawn so Fabi advances
it's the h5 but it's not not much better
Magnus goes for King g3 now rook has to
move and now King to g2 and now the rook
can
longer remain on the H file since
Carlson's rocker controls h4 we look
back to d1 and only now rook to H for
going after this pawn and Carson doesn't
have to worry about any of his other
pawns because his lights prohibition
nicely covers it both of them so far
because Rudy do check King to g3 and now
rook to b8 but now of course Magnus just
gobbles up the pawns so rook captures on
h5 and now again it's two to one but
it's still it's bishops of opposite
color so it's a very very hard to push
for advantage here rook the g8 with
Czech fabi's down upon but he makes
calls and take his King all the way to
the th file as you cannot approach the
the White King so you have to go all the
way back and now the rug cuts off the
King from re-entering the game so King
d2 and now just going going after the
pond so you can activate the Bishop and
rook to f5 now Magnus will now try and
create a bridge so his King can cross
across the G file with Bishop to d4 and
now comes Luke to f3 and here we have
Bishop to e3 and now there's a there's a
very interesting move here that Magnus
found so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find how would you
continue the game here as it's a very
very strong move well I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations unsporting that there
is a nasty discovery lurking in the
position and for those who just want to
enjoy the show it's f5 now the point is
if at any other point you've played f5
without the rope being an g8y we'll just
play each captures an f6 off a song and
there is nothing more for black to hope
for in this game it would just be a draw
but here white is unable to capture and
this means that black now has to pass
pawns
instead of one which is of course twice
as good at least and you also have to
deal with your rope being under attack
you don't really gain anything by
checking the King just runs away so here
Fabi goes after the best shot rookie 8
but now even f4 by Magnus now saying if
you capture here I'm just gonna capture
here and now I already have a look
behind your past pone I'm just gonna
push both of these guys to victory and
there's not much you can do so instead
after f4 Fabi moves the bishop and now
comes Bishop to c4 again a very strong
move by Magnus not a giving time Fabi to
push his passport because of Rudy three
Czech picks up the bishop here so King
c1 end now rook to d3 just the same
better back to a7 getting out of harm's
way and now rook the c3 with Czech we
have King to be one and now rip the c2
threatening even more nasty discoveries
with Bishop to d3 so Fabi needs to
prevent this he goes rook the c8 and now
if you go
Bishop to d3 now it's not it's not gonna
work because here Fabi just straights
and after B captures and c2 checking c1
it doesn't work as well this Bishop
nicely controls the f2 squares you
cannot cross this and the King covers
this so it's not really a problem so
this will not work so Magnus finds
King to g4 and now Bobby has the Fabi
has to do something he goes look the c6
but now the game is completely lost and
well it's very interesting why the game
is completely lost so once again feel
free to pause the video and find the
winning move for Magnus while I give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations and spotting either
rook to a tomb which just offers offers
a trade here and allows then allows for
- of the d3 check on the next move or
even even better if you found Carlson's
idea which is very shocking because here
cross and played Bishop to d3 the move
we already said doesn't work
however after you've played King to g4
it actually does work and here's why so
here if AB you of course went for the
trade it seems similar to the line we've
already shown however after this check
on King c1 now Kings the f5 and now the
King is much closer here and the bishop
must guard the pawn so here if I be
defensive but now comes f3 and now the
bishop will will be overloaded so Bishop
to a7 not allowing f2 now King captures
on e5 we have King Tubby tomb still it's
not very easy to cross but King to f4
saying that ok if you capture my bishop
I just Queen the pawn so you don't even
have to worry about that so much of the
e3 check by Fabi and here Magnus just
played King to g3 and it was in this
position unmoved 64 that Fabiana Khurana
resigned the game and well Magnus
Carlsen also wins Game two now here you
resign because whatever you play is just
game over for example if you we already
mentioned if you capture this guy then
it's just c1 and you bring a queen into
the game the surpass the capture it and
now f2 there is no stopping the pawn if
King here just came here and on the next
move you will whatever white plays you
will Queen the pawn so that's one way to
do it another way is for example if
white tries to keep an eye on the f2
square it's the same idea I just see one
Queen you force the bishop away from the
defense of the F to pawn and check and
the bishop nicely covers f1 so after the
King moves just f1 Queen and of course
it's game over
so of course Bobby knows this and after
King to g3 he resigned the game now
there were all the things Fabi could
have done better this game but he's he's
real and the the the biggest mistake
actually happened on move for in this
position where Fabi missed to go for the
Evans gambit he didn't go for b4 here
he played c3 instead and then
everything else just you know just
happened so that's the game I'd hope you
enjoyed it in Game three
Bobby needed to get two more wins in
this match to even to just force an
Armageddon game however Magnus also had
he had a winning position on several
occasions but in the end the game ended
in a draw but that was enough for Magnus
the the claim went in in the first match
so Fabi needs the win match two and then
he also needs to come back and the win
match three if he wants to go into the
semi-finals
and but it's still not over not gonna
started with a 3-0 victory against
Hikaru Nakamura and then Hikaru bonds
back and then won the match against
Magnus so anything is possible if Fabi
brings his egg a game for the next match
so once again I hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Kyle Mars Mark
Bennett a Joffrey cook a Tom Murphy
enter a name never Stratton for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the finals of the
accessible masters 2020 checking up any
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day